it's this is kind of like a movie right
so like guy builds huge tech company
becomes billionaire has life-changing
life-changing accident changes
everything gives it all up explores the
world it becomes like a mug
you've never met sean right
no
say something you don't like you can
just fire sam and that pretty much takes
care of the whole thing i love that
i've always wanted
and uh okay so you uh you listen to the
first episode the very first episode or
just like a random episode i ripped
through like a couple little random
things okay i heard you guys talking
about the wright brothers and some
random [__]
okay and from that random uh stumble
uh describe what you heard what what
kind of podcast is this
um
it's a podcast for entrepreneurs uh to
get inspiration and ideas uh
yeah it sounds like by the way i'm not
being condescending i thought it sounded
sounded great but i heard it sounded
great
like something i would i would listen to
but that's what i was going to ask you
you know is this something you would
have earlier in your entrepreneurial
career yes because now you know you're
now you're mister i've made it you're
you know you don't need that
inspirational juice anymore or maybe you
do i don't know
enough never enough inspirational juice
look he doesn't listen to podcasts like
ours sean he just buys them
yeah
most people listen i purchase uh so one
thing we i don't know what you plan on
talking about but one thing we could
talk about that
might be interesting is my snowmobile
accident
yeah so like we're live now so we're
we're recording now so
yes we let's we could do it so what
we'll do i'll ask you about that i want
to know about that and then also we're
going to talk to you about some
different business ideas and i've got a
few that i want to ask your opinion on
but um so let me do it let me do the
super short intro this is brian halligan
he's the c was that you were the ceo of
hubspot now the chairman or exec
chairman or something very fancy like
that something fancy like that yes all
right cool and you um you basically like
like i think like two weeks so basically
uh hubspot bought the hustle my company
and like two weeks after you got into a
really bad accident right yeah
and you like broke like a dozen a dozen
bones or i mean it was pretty serious
yeah
i was like i hope ryan's okay but also i
was i was like if this deal if this
would have happened like two weeks
before the deal closed i wonder if that
would have changed anything yeah cause i
was a big proponent of the deal i was
really happy we did it um
i tell you the whole story i'm just
gonna go
uh i was snowmobiling up in vermont with
my son luke and
we were we were right yo we're we're
right in the middle
of nowhere right square in the middle of
nowhere
and
we were cruising along and he was he was
cruising along
and
i asked him to slow down he just kind of
got confused between the gas and the
brake
and
um he put his jammed his finger on the
gas and he just panicked a little bit
and we basically flew off a cliff and
landed on a tree
and wow i don't remember neither of us
actually he's 17. neither of us remember
the accident at all
and we were both passed out before the
we hit the tree and passed out after so
we're both lying there in the snow
passed out i wake up first i wake him up
and we are banged up like it's like a
cartoon or arms and legs or
you know we're a mess
and i thought
this is it it's 4 30 in the afternoon
it's freezing cold
we're in the middle of nowhere
no one knows where we are
we're gonna die tonight um
and i reached into my pocket and grabbed
my phone thinking there's no way there's
signal and i
i had three but i had enough signal i
called nine i never called 911 my whole
life called 9-1-1
she picked up i roughly described where
we were right square in the middle of
nowhere
and um
then they call in the troops and the
troops in vermont are volunteer
firefighters um they're not you know
professional emts and ambulances and
stuff
and it took him about an hour and
one interesting thing that happened is
they kind of came but one guy who found
us came from below us
and he marched up the hill and he's
yelling kind of yelling for us and we
were yelling back and he finally got to
us he starts asking us questions he says
wait
are you brian halligan i'm like yeah
he said hey i'm joey i'm the guy who
plows your driveway
[Laughter]
like that's a volunteer firefighter and
they are bad
asses these volunteer firefighters so
they strapped us to sleds pulled us
straight up out of the you know ravine
back onto the trails and then you know
helicoptered us to the hospital
when you're laying there are you just in
an incredible amount of pain what's
broken incredible amount of pain what
what did what broke what was broken on
your body
i broke like 12 or 13 bones but but my
i could show the pictures but my left
knee
like my left knee my tibia my my uh
femur and tibia broke
my right wrist broke my left elbow
trash my right left shoulder trash and
then my
i already had a lot of loose screws up
top and now the screws get even looser
just like you had like a concussion or
something yeah i had a concussion and um
yours i broke my i hit the tree so hard
broke my helmet oh my god and you're
what about your son
he was banged up too he broke his femur
which is a terrible bone bone to break
and he broke his knee and he got a
concussion so he was banged up then you
had to like you had to cut him out of
the will i mean after that for this
accident
he's doing great i mean he's 17 so he
bounced back fast like he was at soccer
practice today and stuff so
really really bounce back
you're sitting in this chair it looks
like you're not a wheelchair just no
listen no no no no i was in a wheelchair
for three and a half months though a
good long chunk i can walk i can drive i
can do like a light hike
like my brain is 100 i'm fine i think my
brain's actually better
uh
and
and what percentage of you you know sort
of attributes this to the hustle deal
the timing is coincidental
i mean
it was the adrenaline from the hustle
deal got the whole whole thing
you um and like so basically
you know i don't know so brian uh
hubspot at this point is like a maybe i
forget the market cap today maybe in the
30 billion range uh revenue north of a
billion
employees at like what 2500 or 3000 like
so this we're talking like a really big
company at this point but you had been
the
the ceo from the beginning
and after this accident you
you know removed yourself you replaced
yourself and now you're the executive
chairman did the accident
when you're having this like near-death
moment where you're like what am i doing
with my life like what what
did it was it like a crisis like this
like when you're done
uh like recovering
it's a perfect question
lying there in the snow thinking i was
gonna die i thought to myself
yourself
how was your life are you proud of it
are you enjoying your life as you're
thinking about it a second time
if you live
what do you want to change about your
life
um it was sort of a reset button for me
and i think over time as i look back at
the accident
it may be the best thing that ever
happened to me because i've made a lot
of life changes since then that um like
what what what sorts of changes yeah
i broke up with my girlfriend of a
couple years
um
[Music]
i
you know my whole life was hubspot it
wasn't i really didn't spend any time on
any other causes like i read a check
and so i went on a
kind of a broad search for a cause that
i could put my energy and
some cash into
and i found one that i fell in love with
it's called the woods hole oceanographic
institute it's like the harvard of the
ocean yeah i've hung out there a bit
right next to coffee obsession the
coffee shop down there exactly exactly
um and
what got me about the institute
and besides the fact that i live near it
is and knew nothing about it despite
living here for 10 years was
a blatant optimism amongst the
scientists on their ability to slow and
reverse climate change leveraging the
ocean in a sustainable way like it
really caught me by surprise as i was
walking the halls and getting to know
them there's a lot of optimism and
there's a lot of stuff
on the lab there that they think can
scale on a global level so i pick them
and i'm on their board and i'm doing a
lot with them these days that's been
very exciting so
yeah i've done a lot of different stuff
like now i used to work out sort of
casually every day i'm like get my heart
rate up into the 160s daily like i'm not
screwing around anymore i want to live a
long
healthy life like i'm 54 and
i'd like to live a long healthy life i
don't want to be an old man when i'm 70.
i want to want to be a very vibrant
seven-year-old what have you been
reading since your accident
is there like did you did it put you
down this different path of learning and
you're like okay i want to explore this
path or this
spiritual thing or this giving thing i
don't know uh like a a different
trajectory
initially it was like lock yourself in a
room and keep it dark and don't read and
don't uh
don't see anything when you've got a uh
concussion yeah yeah
i read random stuff but i you know i'll
tell you one thing that surprised me is
uh when you have a concussion like i had
a neurosurgeon helping me i had a shrink
helping me i had a shaman come and visit
me
i had all kinds of people consulting me
on how to recover from
a concussion and
from the neurosurgeon to the shaman they
all said to do one thing
what do you think that thing is
sleep
meditate meditate meditate yeah they all
were just like you got to meditate
that's the way you're going to get
through it and what what were you a
meditator before i was not i never
really met or i tried and i was just so
bad at it that i gave up
and so
yeah i'm a pretty big meditator these
days so like
i'm just looking right here at the books
i'm reading like one of the books is
becoming supernatural
um
i'm not sure about it yet i'm only
through chapter one but it's basically a
meditation book i'm taking a class on
vedic i'm not even sure i'm saying that
right meditation next week because i
want to get better at it just seems like
it unlocks a lot
um so this is this is kind of like a
movie right so like guy builds like
i have no i don't know if this is true
or not but guy builds huge tech company
becomes billionaire has life-changing
life-changing accident changes
everything gives it all up explores the
world it becomes like uh it saves saves
the option starts
and
yeah
this is like this is like uh this is a
movie right this is this is how it's
going
to be
the other thing i would say is i'm still
involved with hubspot so i'm still like
today i've had four hubspot calls so i'm
not i'm i'm very much engaged with
hubspot i'm just not engaged in stuff i
don't like to do like i don't like doing
one-on-ones with people and doing
performance reviews and talking about
their salary and stuff like that i
really i'm not great at it and but i'm
able to work on the product stuff and
the vision stuff um
the stuff that really motivates me so
it's it's really worked out but i'm
still very busy with the hubspot stuff
and i always wondered this like uh when
i was at twitch
emmett is the ceo he was the original
founder right so he's like 10 years in
and um and he basically went from like
you know starting the thing with two two
three you know buddies basically to okay
two thousand employees
and you know whatever millions of
millions of users and for a long time
his thing was like you know yeah i'm not
the professional ceo manager type i'll
get coaching there so that i'm not like
awful at it yeah but uh you know i'm
great with product and growth and i'm
gonna like there was like this perpetual
candidate search for a chief product
officer that somehow was never getting
filled and it's like everyone knew it's
because emmett loves to do it and it's
great about it
i had a little of this yeah i think it's
pretty common to do for this to happen
or the ceo's like well that's the thing
i like don't don't take away the one
thing i like when there's like the rest
of it is just firefighting and politics
like you know i'm not not super into
that bit and then you know eventually
found it when i was there found somebody
who was a you know really good product
leader and an engineering leader and
basically
over you know over that year i saw that
person take more of that role and then i
was like oh emma what are you gonna do
now and he was like i'm gonna work on
like you know the vision and the long
trip strategy i was like
yeah but like you know when you wake up
what do you what do you do you just sit
there and i'm gonna think about the
vision right now it's like that's such a
weird what do you do day to day and i
never really understood
what that meant and so like would you
say i think i would i work on you know
the vision and strategy now
you wake up what the heck do you do
okay so today there was a bunch of
emails back and forth between darmesh
and i about what subspot looked like
five years from now um
so literally i woke up thinking about
exactly that right
it turns out so you're doing like it's
like long form writing so you're just
like writing out you guys it's like a
basically an email brainstorming session
yeah it wasn't even that long it was
emails back and forth
um and just different product ideas and
different areas we could go into um
and then i read a lot and so you guys
probably saw that amazon came out with
like a billion new products yesterday
that looked kind of interesting actually
it's just amazing how much new stuff
they had and how well it tied together i
think that started the thread like holy
crap is there a lot of innovation coming
out of that company and yeah there's a
lot of r d in there but it's amazing the
amount of innovation coming out of there
and uh i think that sort of started it
by the way did you see this infinidash
thing that came from from amazon did you
guys see this no what is it so so aws so
amazon launches all these different
products and uh
somebody said somebody basically on
twitter
goes and
they go oh my god
you know aws infinidash
looks like a game changer um and i think
you know werner vogels who's like one of
their kind of like cto scientists yeah
gto types he tweets out like you know at
the end at the hashtag infinidash event
tonight blah blah celebrating
and then um and it's a fake product
there is no product called infinidash it
was like just like a meme but people
started kind of memeing it into
existence so someone immediately
responds they go i'm buying open dash
dot io so i don't get locked into aws as
an as an open source alternative to
infinidash
and then signal the big messaging app
that has like 50 million users was like
um you know we're hiring
an engineer with an emphasis on infiniti
dash lifecycle manager
and um there's like youtube videos with
infinite demos
and like people like i'm an infinite
consultant and it just like took on a
life and if you knew it was fake you
knew but everybody kind of played the
party that's awesome the whole bunch of
people thought it was real that's
awesome that's awesome ryan you um i saw
this like i saw this graph i think it
was from darmesh
at a talk
at saster and the graph was pretty
amazing it was like it was like maybe
hubspot's first five years of revenue
and i'm almost positive i was trying to
like read the graph and it wasn't all
marked out clearly but i'm almost
positive it said something like in year
three you already had like six million
in arr is that accurate
i doubt it
it's too low or too high and too high
too high i would say the thing about sas
businesses that's fascinating is it
takes you approximately forever to get
to 5 million in ar
uh but once you get to 5 50 is like bam
you know it's tomorrow well that's what
i thought but like it took us so long no
no i think i think you're misreading
that graph it took us a long time to get
to 5 million an hour
it took us a long time to get to a
million
how long did it take i forget but it's
we had a lot of churn our product you
know
we've turned into a product-centric
company a design-centric company and a
customer-centric company but it took us
a long time to get there and so we had
lots of customers coming in but we had
lots of churn in those early days eating
away at our growth um so it took us a
while it took us
it felt like forever to get to a million
i remember and then forever to get to 10
and then all of a sudden bam 100 then
bam two you know it started happening
fast and even now like we got to a
billion and
you know it's starting to happen really
fast now well and like your first there
was like the joke was like i actually
disagree with you i think you i think
darmash maybe
squished that
crap a little bit yeah i i i could have
read it wrong but for some reason i was
like wait they hit they hit something
they hit like 15 like something we
didn't break any records on that [__]
well and he made a joke he was like the
first five people on the team were like
brian who was like an mba sales person
and then like another marketing guy
another like sales person and then
another operations person and then me
who was a technical person and i
actually had to build the thing and
they're like this combination is a
horrible combination for the early an
early team yet somehow it kind of worked
i actually i think his point on that was
the early team was
a bunch of
people we knew from sloan that we got
mbas with like
people we thought were super sharp they
started them as contractors then we
hired them
and that
in a lot of ways that was good in a lot
of ways that was bad um in the early
days the hub spot there was a lot of
pluses doing minuses to it the first
person the first
very few people know this but the the
the first version of hubspot was built
by darmesh and these two guys in egypt
that he found through
um found online put a test out there
and
pharah maui and i forgot the other guy's
name
and they built like the prototype of
those three built the prototype outside
here's how hubspot worked in the early
days
all day long i would be using the
product demoing the products pitching
the product
and using it to run our marketing and
then at the end of the day i'd write up
you know here's the
10 most important bugs i found and then
at night darmesh is a night owl and
those guys are obviously working at
night because they're in egypt they'd
fix all 10 and create like 50 more
[Laughter]
so it's just a constant whack-a-mole
that first year and then we hired a guy
a kid from yale who was a
he was a poli-sci major but he was a
computer scientist on the side who's
really good named patrick fitzsimmons
and he joined the team
and then we started getting going um and
then we hired a guy from mit
who ran engineering and then we ran and
then we hired a guy that ran darmesh's
last company he was an engineer and then
we really started cooking but that first
version was written in egypt of all
places
wow and you know when we think uh like i
think back about upshot what's that
what's the name of the company option
upshot what is
that when you can outsource your dev
projects
what's the other one oh desk or elance
or
upwork
upwork it used to be called yeah
i heard stories about a friend who was
early at uber and they used to like this
was like a secret that they didn't tell
a lot of people but one of the
co-founders of uber is mexican oscar
he's from mexico i forget his last name
oscar salazar or something like that and
they used to make jokes that like some
of the early code was in spanish and
they couldn't fix it and i was like why
i was like why what's going on he's like
well apparently you know just like you
don't think about it but uber was just
like any other
small business that didn't have any
money and one of the co-founders was
mexican and he lived in mexico and they
had their peers or friends like it was
like contractors that they could only
afford and coat make the early uber code
and there was this joke that like a lot
of the early stuff was in spanish and
they couldn't fix it
and so it's kind of funny to hear that
yeah that's right it's funny you say
that you don't you don't ever think of
uber as like a struggling little startup
with no money but everyone starts that
way
except for today there's so much money
sloshing around people don't start that
way they start with like five million
bucks in their bank account well the
uber guys had money they just thought of
it as a side project they were they
didn't think about it like this is going
to dominate the world they thought of it
like this would be cool we'll roll
around in black cars in san francisco
and not have to worry about taxis
i don't think they had that much money i
know travis had had an exit but i don't
think that they were like
right through stumble upon right he had
done well like he didn't i don't think
they were rich enough that they could
like put three or four million dollars
into a business before it really was
they knew it was gonna be worth it like
i i don't think it may be that i mean
those guys are hyper connected right
like they sure they can raise a seed
round if they needed to um so
we were talking last episode about this
company called nerd wallet and the nerd
wall the story the the part that's
relevant it's basically it's a big
finance kind of like blog basically and
um and they make a ton of money because
they rank at the top of the search
engine for
uh best credit card best credit card for
business whatever and they get a bunch
of they make like 100 million dollars
off that
referral essentially at the end of the
day but they got there by making great
content and like it was like
tortoise and the hair everybody else was
like
you know just trying to farm as much
content as you could these guys are
trying to do quality content and for two
years they're sitting in their apartment
just banging away at blog posts and like
the traffic really wasn't it wasn't
impressive and i was telling sam i was
like if i had started this company i
would have pivoted 10 times by then if i
was advising them i'd be like guys look
at the data this is not working but they
had a lot of faith and they sort of kept
going and there's these like
perseverance stories and they hear these
other stories that are like well
we we tried this thing we saw the
signals and so we made a shift in
strategy
and these like inflection points are the
hardest thing because as an entrepreneur
you never know which one is this one of
those moments where i should be
persevering in spite of the data or
should i be taking the signals and
making a dramatic shift in what i'm
doing pivoting in some way and i think
everybody has like i look back at any
startup i started and i see multiple
moments where maybe i made the wrong
decision maybe i made the right decision
it's very hard to say because you never
know what would have come out the other
side when you look back at early hubspot
was there are there any moments like
that where you know either it was not
when it was not working and you decided
either to persevere or shift in your
strategy shift in your the way you guys
were doing something
yeah there have been two big pivots in
hubspot's history that people don't talk
about
um
the first pivot was about six months in
we were building kind of a general
purpose platform for
for legal firms we call it legal spot
this is probably something we were still
in business school but we were spending
time on it we had a prototype of it and
we would go to law offices and we demo
it and try to get people excited about
it and they weren't super psyched about
it but there was a little piece of it
that was
um
around grading your website and around
seo that the law firms got excited about
and got excited about the lead gen piece
and we stuck with this legal spot idea
for a really long time and we're just
getting very mediocre feedback and
finally george and i were like why don't
we just work on that one thing they keep
asking us about and so we killed
legalspot and we built website greater
and we built the lead generation system
and then we killed the idea of
verticalizing it and went horizontal and
sold it to all our friends and startups
basically
so that was the first huge pivot we had
was giving up basically on the original
idea and the reason the original idea
was there was when we were in business
school they put you in little pods for
uh for stuff and there was a woman in
our pod who was terrific who had started
a company in the legal space and
convinced us there was something really
there
um and she might have been right if we
stuck with it but uh we ended up
pivoting away from that and she ended up
not joining hubspot
the second huge pivot we had is we were
a marketing app software company i mean
we built
we started with we started as a web 2.0
company back a hundred thousand years
ago with seo and blogging and social
media and we were good at helping people
get in front page of digging reddit and
stumble upon [__] like that wait
that that was the service was that you
were good at getting people on top of
dig and reddit we were good at helping
people get turn strangers into visitors
on their site with no advertising money
so start your blog get good at search
engine optimization start a twitter face
get going on dig get going on reddit and
start building credibility there and so
create these channels into your business
basically that's that's how hubspot
effectively started but we were seo
geeks at heart
and then we moved into marketing
automation which was an obvious move
because everyone was buying hubspot but
then they'd buy marketo or they'd buy
pardot or they buy one of these other
platforms you're like they'd spend a lot
of money on it we're like you know we
get into that business and so we moved
into that business but the big pivot was
when we said we're not a marketing apps
company anymore we're a crm platform
company and then we've really turned
ourselves on our head and we made that
decision about
seven years ago and that turned out to
be a very very good pivot for us and
we're still in the middle of it like we
have so much more work to do on our apps
and so much more work to do on our
platform like it really works well our
customers love it you're talking about
um
oh i know i was gonna ask when you guys
were early on when did the company
launch oh five
oh six oh six
yeah what what why don't you know we
launched it that's when we officially
started it
actually we never really launched the
company we just kind of started it
when you were doing that
what i mean you know your behemoth now
but what percentage of it do you
attribute to
you just picked the right idea
in a huge market
and had fantastic timing and it kind of
you got pulled to success
compared to you're just uh you know
you're you made the right decisions and
you're smart and talented and skilled i
mean what percentage of that came down
to
it was just we got lucky that we saw
this early on and it kind of worked out
that we just stuck with it versus
we're really
healthy dose of both are are a very
healthy
dose of both
um
the thing we saw
in the and the thing that anchors me is
i
i just watch the way people shop in the
way they buy and the way they evaluate
products i'm sort of look like a little
bit of an anthropologist of watching
people buy stuff
and
i noticed two things that were going on
first of all
all the marketing stuff that i had done
my whole career whether it was emailing
you know doing email marketing or was
advertising or cold calling or anything
didn't work because people like caller
id they had spam protection that ad
blockers like
it's broken and at the same time
people no longer were going to like idc
and you know gartner and all this stuff
they were reading blogs and they were
reading
articles on social media and
uh they were going to google and so
those two things just kind of clicked
inside our head and like there's a
transformation that needs to happen from
this very old school outbound
interruption-based marketing to this new
school inbound marketing you have to
match the way you market to the way
people actually want to shop and buy and
what the nice thing about it is your
success in that new type of marketing
was much much more about the width of
your brain than the width of your wallet
you didn't need a lot of money and so we
initially sort of targeted
small businesses we moved up to some uh
to larger businesses these days but uh
that's sort of how it got going and we
it turns out we were right about that
and we were early on that thesis
and i remember there was a decision
point in the early days of hubspot like
we were starting to get traction it was
starting to go and we were unsure you
know is this going to be a big company
is this going to be like the two of us
are going to fund this we'll do some
angel thing or is this going to be a go
big or go home and i remember looking at
it at some point in time it was like
we're right about inbound
and other people are noticing we're
right we gotta like raise a lot of money
and go fast because some people are
gonna start copying us and people did
copy us like crazy and so at some point
we sort of flipped the switch from
you know we got a little business that's
going pretty well we may have 50 people
we might end up doing a lot of services
to know we're building a big software
company and it was the realization that
we were early and right about this idea
of inbound and and
one of the reasons people love the pod
is because we
we started off with kind of like what
we're doing a little bit now which is
interviews with people who are
successful say hey how'd you do it
what'd you do what was it like and
somewhere along the way i just said hey
sam let's record an extra episode on a
friday
what i really wanted to do is help him
promote trends and i was like let's just
talk about trends let's talk about what
are some opportunities your your
research crew has found and let's just
shoot the [__] about it it'll sell some
trans subscriptions and it'll be i think
interesting like it's like how we talk
offline let's just record it
and um what that started was
a lot of the podcast now is basically
brainstorming and just shooting the [__]
about well today here's what i see as
some opportunities maybe i'm not going
to do them because i'm already doing two
businesses my hands are full but if
somebody's out there looking you know i
think this is really interesting this is
where i would be sniffing right now and
so i don't know if that's hard for you
because you're so
concerned by a large problem
let me ask a little bit differently so
earlier you you had this thing called
legal spot now you guys are just your
hubspot which is you know
the the crm for like you know any
business ever
but
i see a lot of companies pop up that say
they are the hubspot for x so you said
you started as legal spot now there
probably is like are hubspot just for
the legal industry we are hubspot only
for dentists we are hubspot only for
doctors whatever
what do you think about those and if you
if you're not a fan or you don't think
that they like are necessarily gonna
have legs which industry
do you think could have legs where you
could have a hubspot for x that you guys
just simply can't meet because their
their knees are so specific as soon as
you brought this up i was like there's
an infinite number of opportunities for
people to build stuff on top of hubspot
that's vertical specific
and so someone should build a legal spot
on top of hubspot someone should build a
hospital spot on top of hubspot like
whatever they want and it's all sort of
there the apis are there like there is
incredible low hanging fruit for
entrepreneurs to build and then just
sell it to our install base all the new
customers there's lots of channels you
can sell through hubspot that is
it's it's it's probably the upside on it
you're probably not going to build a 100
billion dollar company but you're the
beta on it's low you can build a good
company make good money by doing that
are there any success stories of people
doing this so far there's a bunch of
them there's these kids in um
in
the uk
not kids they're in their 20s but
they built something called org chart
hub on top of hubspot which was hey i'm
working on selling to procter gamble and
they pulled in procter gamble's org
chart and then as a team you can go and
change that org chart around as a change
and it became wildly popular inside of
hubspot for sales reps using the product
and now they've built a series of
different apps inside of hubspot that's
worked out
that's that was the first of them now
there's a whole bunch of them popping up
have you seen um have you seen the org
a company called the org okay so it's i
think it might be the org.com actually
uh is it similar idea something like
that yeah and so all they do is it's a
database of org charts and they recently
raised
i think they've raised two rounds but a
recent raise was a 20 million dollar
round from founders fund or something
like that like a tier one vc
this org chart thing actually like it
just happened to it yeah and one of the
very first brainstorms when daniel gross
joined we had brainstormed this because
i had said it's so hard to know who the
heck is who inside
companies linkedin has become impossible
to know exactly and we said this is a
wedge to build a new style of linkedin
linkedin basically took all said we'll
take the resume
and then we'll create you know basically
like the social network on top of this
database of resumes well why don't you
create a database of org charts get
people to crowdsource because i think
people like to say here's my hierarchy
here's where i am in the hierarchy so
people are willing to fill it in for
their company and you can crowdsource
that and then use that as like the basis
of a new style of linkedin i think
that's what these guys are doing almost
to a tee
i think i think linkedin is there's
certain companies that i think are ripe
for disruption i think there
um
that work chart hub thing is is cool the
company who i bet is kicking themselves
is the it's the you know the information
do you guys subscribe to the information
yeah they have an org chart thing they
haven't worked for things it's awesome
by the way
i bet they're kicking themselves they
didn't spin that out into a company and
raise a venture for it and crowdsource
that because
it's very good um i i refer to it often
actually yeah that's the media company
dna though um all right so what about
non-hubspot related what if you were 21
today and you're thinking about business
ideas or you just graduated business
school like when you started hubspot
what do you what would have your your
fascination your curiosity where would
you be building what opportunities have
you seen that you're like okay if i had
a clean slate of time here's where i
would go what i would go for okay i like
to think about like the big trends and
then sort of zero in on okay what's an
idea on the big trend so
i just think just the most enormous
trend that's going on and i saw in
hubspot's board meeting last week so
i've been out for six months i went to
the first board meeting we had an hour
and a half discussion
about the environment and we have this
whole chart on how we eventually want to
get to a zero carbon footprint
every board meeting in the world is
having that same conversation
and that's a hard thing for companies to
pull off
and that's just the beginning at this
point
you know europe sort of taxes carbon the
us doesn't tax carbon eventually the u.s
is going to figure that tax department i
just think clean tech ocean tech
there's there's gonna be trillions of
dollars made in that industry
explain that from a big company's
perspective because i've never you know
our business was much smaller than
hubspot and so like when i thought about
climate change i'm like yeah that's
important to me as a person but like my
business i'm just trying to make payroll
like i can't even think about that at
the moment like you know how my company
fits into that
you guys are much bigger what
what do you um
like from your perspective what does
that mean you're you're willing to spend
money in order to
do oh we are we're spending huge money
so yeah tell me like well how much are
you spending and what are you spending
that money on and what's the motivating
factor there
is like a dollar and cents thing is it
to look good is it to feel good what
what what where's the what's the
motivating factor there from uh from a
buyer's perspective
i think fundamentally it's a moral issue
for hubspot it's board and it's
leadership team and we all are behind it
um
even if you didn't moralistically
believe in that type of stuff your
employees are going to force you to do
it your investors are going to force you
to do it your customers are going to
eventually force you to do it so you
don't have a choice if you're a company
hubspot size or even a little bit bigger
than where you are sam eventually your
employees are going to be like you know
what are we doing about this you know
they were actually
asking you about it in your group
meetings um and so what hubspot's done
is you know we've tried to lower our
carbon footprint as much as possible get
our energy now through wind
fund uh sustainable projects like
forestry projects river projects
renewal projects out there to offset
some of the energy we consume
changing policies to consume less
carbon dioxide so at this point
you know we're at zero from the
beginning of hubspot but we want to
consume
far far less we don't want to be buying
offsets how are you tracking how much
how do you track that is there like a
dashboard i mean i i'm it's very hard to
track and the companies who are trying
to track it are the same are like your
auditors like the price waterhouse and
people like that and there's no great
way to track it so it's a big business
opportunity for companies that can
figure out how to track that stuff well
have you heard of um what was the thing
we were talking about sean was
so it stands for leadership and energy
and environmental design have you ever
have you ever seen a building um yeah
like
a lead scored yeah or something like
that
but we were looking it up on the show we
were talking about that we're like it's
kind of interesting and so it's a
non-profit so you can actually see their
sales
and their revenue is like 36 or 38
million dollars and it's something i
think it's highly recurring
and uh is that it was kind of a shocking
business and it was weird it's like what
on earth made all these people believe
that lead is like the thing
yeah you know it's like jd power for
cars it's like i don't actually or
gartner it's like i don't know i think
they just kind of said that they're the
experts and everyone kind of bought into
it and yeah and i'm like i think i got
similar
yes i i think even beyond that like
carbon sequestration is going to have to
become a thing if we're going to solve
it and people are investing in ways to
pull carbon out of the air
that are really expensive right now
i'm optimistic on our ability to pull
carbon out of the air with the ocean in
a more effective way
but at some point you're gonna need to
be able to say to hubspot to microsoft
to whoever hey you purchase a certain
amount of credits around carbon
sequestration
is it legit and have a true measurement
system that's quantitative not just like
a
most of the stuff out there is is
survey-based did you do this did you
just do this and you sort of
self-certify it right uh there needs to
be a more more like nielsen than jd
power
you know right
and there's there's a huge opportunity
there
so let's say you're right okay so that's
the that's the mega trend and you say
okay i could i could see the world is
moving in this direction and it's it's
going to need some catalyst some
companies that help accelerate it in
that direction pull the future forward
where's your inclination when or how do
you approach something like that because
i think for most entrepreneurs they say
okay climate change well okay that's
daunting like
uh i gotta save the planet all right
that's a sort of a big idea here i don't
really know where to start and then
there's all sorts of frameworks you can
use like picks and shovels businesses
like how do you sell tools to the people
who are going to be trying to fix this
problem or investing in in a portfolio
of companies that are all doing this
there's deep science where like you know
would you go find a partner like darmesh
who's got an idea around some technical
solution to pulling second carbon out of
the air how would you actually go about
approaching it once you decide okay this
is where the puck is going uh how would
you how would you actually tackle that
as an entrepreneur okay so i just rolled
the clock back to i'm an mba
at sloane
and i'm looking for a partner in a
business opportunity and back then it
made sense darmash and i made perfect
sense um
we were both super passionate about
small businesses and web 2.0 and
disruption and we took all the same
classes and we liked each other
at this point i wouldn't be looking for
a darmesh i'd be looking for somebody
from the other side of the university
most likely
that could help me figure this like how
do i get more plastic out of the ocean
or how do i once i get that plastic out
of the ocean turn it into products in a
much more efficient way how do i get
really smart about carbon sequestration
how do we get kelp to soak up all the
carbon in the world and then drop that
kelp into the bottom of the ocean and
sequester it for thousands of years i'd
be looking for
scientists and engineers who are working
on that type of stuff
and i think it's it's it's endlessly
fascinating i think it's it's it's
and i think the answers are there i i
actually am confident that the
capitalist system the startup
environment can solve some of these
problems like you read the news and you
just think oh it's now we're never never
gonna fix it like it's the end of the
world and when you're ever gonna get
that 1.5 degrees celsius it's going to
blow but actually i think startups and
entrepreneurs and that same gusto that
went into the biotech east ecosystem the
same gusto that went into
the software ecosystem i think that's
going to happen in clean tech in ocean
tech and i think it'll work did you see
sean did you see the i think you're
friends with this guy the old ceo of
reddit who has a new business and
it's like he's like johnny appleseed
it's like only planting trees or
something like that right terraform i
think is the name of it what is that do
you know what that is yeah so this guy
ishon wong and um he was i think early
kind of facebook um and then he ended up
becoming this he was hired as ceo of
reddit uh he was like basically kind of
like a user of reddit that just ended up
becoming the ceo because he had the
right tech background and now what he's
doing is
he's got this startup i'm trying to find
the name real quick um
i'll find it terraform or terraformation
and yeah what he's doing is basically
he's uh he he he was started thinking
about climate like at last i don't know
or i don't know when he started thinking
about it but he started really like
making that his next project over the
lasting of five years and i think what
he decided was like
oh i think one way we can attack this is
to find large plots of land and we need
to plant like millions of trees in this
area and we need to basically re-terrify
the terra formation sort of like re you
know resurfacing of the way you use land
and um and that's what we're gonna do
and i think it's called terraformation
inc is the name of his company and he
found this plot of land i think near
hawaii or something like that
and um and he's basically published his
idea of like here's a full solution to
climate change that can be done in under
30 years
and um
and you know he's got kind of like a
bold view of what that what that looks
like i don't know all the details he
hasn't really said all the details just
yet but he's been revealing more and
more over time it's it's one to watch
it's one to to kind of keep an eye on it
yeah
the climatetech vc community is going to
explode in the next couple years
i think chamoth said something like like
this is the number one thing that i i
want to invest in
but the problem is and he actually just
made an investment they launched it
announced it today i think it's called
drone seeds
and i was reading about it i was i think
it's like these custom drones that
basically uh
is it they do it before a fire happens
in a forest they go and they map out
where they think fires will happen and i
don't know exactly how it works but
somehow they can guess where they think
a fire is going to happen and they'll
help fix it before it happens i believe
that that's what it is it's called drone
seeds
just invested into it but the but he
basically said he's like this is the
main thing that i'm focused on for you
know the next few decades and when he
said that i was like okay that's that's
cool uh in theory i'm totally behind
this but i was thinking i'm like but i
have no idea how to solve it like i
it's such a grand huge thing that like
so you're now investing and or working
with um
you know scientists at uh uh uh i forget
what what was it called um who which
solo should you grab against yes and i'm
like well that's just like incredibly
intimidating um and then i think like i
think like because i mean like it's so
much that's so much more challenging
than just sitting in your room with
darmesh and just coding something and
then calling someone asking to buy it um
both are hard but one seems like way
more
you can get to market a lot quicker
building software that's for sure yeah
and i was thinking of other ideas in
this space because i'm like well like
i'm behind this i like money like what's
this huge trend like let's if i can if
you can build a huge company and help
the world that sounds like a win-win um
but i was i was i was struggling to get
my hands on something that is actually
interesting uh that can actually be
attainable
there's a bunch of people working on
um measurement systems like our
measurements are horrible on global
warming beyond just the aggregate
temperature of the globe like
measurement systems of the tides and you
tell that measurement that measurement
to the insurance companies so they know
when the you know big storm is coming um
and getting really precise about that
kind of stuff systems to measure the
salinity of the oceans the temperature
of the ocean the temperature of the
atmosphere and using all that
information to input to the carbon
exchanges that happen in europe and
hopefully globally some day like there's
going to be a whole stock mark you think
with there's a there's a stock market
there's a commodities market there's
nasdaq there's the new york stock
exchange that's going to happen for
carbon and think of all the businesses
that happened around that marketplace
there's this company
right now that i see being advertised
everywhere it's called i think it's
called aspiration
and basically have you brian noticed
that there's like all these new credit
card companies coming out basically what
they do i'm kind of dumbing it down but
i believe this is exactly how it works
they just partner with mastercard
mastercard typically takes one percent
of the purchase price from the merchant
and makes money that way mastercard then
says hey if anyone starts a new credit
card system and you're able to convince
these people to sign up we'll split that
with you and that's kind of
that's kind of dumbed down and there's
this new company called aspiration i
think it's called and we predicted this
on trends
shockingly like this is something that
like we nailed way before this company
came out and it's called aspiration and
what they do is and i have no idea how
they do this but whenever you make a
purchase
it tells you
on your phone how uh how much carbon it
used or you know what what the impact on
the environment was and
when i heard about this i'm like i don't
buy this i can't believe someone like i
care about this stuff but like that's
just amazing that someone's willing to
switch credit cards just for this reason
because switching credit cards are pain
in the ass and these guys i think
they've raised over 100 million dollars
and they've attracted
so many new customers just on this idea
and it was shockingly interesting i i i
never in a million years would have
thought that that would take off like it
did
yep i think this is a huge huge trillion
dollar industry it's going to be the
like software industry is a huge
industry biotech's a huge industry this
is going to be a giant industry and
there's lots of ways to get at it um but
it's it's a different it's a different
model it's not just you know hacking
together something on the weekend
testing it and then iterating on it it's
a little different so if climate is a
trend a big trend a big wave that you
believe in
what are some things that you see other
entrepreneurs doing that you are less
excited about or you you're not a
believer in is there some trends because
there's sometimes head fakes or things
that are too early uh that they're you
know the time is not now um i'm curious
what do you see or the time has passed
you're not a believer in you're not
interested in that sort of thing you
know ye old enterprise software
companies
with ye old uh giant outside sales
forces
um it just feels like the time has
passed to build that kind of thing and
i've predicted that before and been
wrong um
but it feels like there's a new breed of
company that sells in a new way and they
start with small businesses whether it's
shopify or it's stripe or it's hubspot
like
there's a new way to build a company and
it's not targeting
fortune 500 companies like when i see
these companies starting like yeah we're
targeting the fortune 500 like
take the technology piece away
just all the compliance work you have to
do to be able to sell to those companies
and all the boxes you need to check to
get in there and then the sales model
it's just like oh good luck
it's a it's a that's a tough road to
help and i want to read a couple of
tweets that you had put out and i want
to hear you kind of elaborate on a
little bit so one is um
you know you need to manage your if
something on long lines if you need to
manage your creative people with loose
reigns and that's from lauren michaels
the the sort of i think he's a producer
or the creator of saturn out live
for a long time so what was uh
what struck what circuit chord with you
about that
okay
you brought some you actually brought up
something earlier that was really
interesting about uh the twitch ceo
uh
so in the early days of hubspot i'm not
a product guy by the way by training or
by dna for that i i think someone
described you i believe it was kip i'm a
sales guy he said you're the best you're
the best salesperson he's ever met yes
i'm a salesperson
and i grew up in sale i grew up in
enterprise sales which is ironic because
i just said i think that industry died
um
but um
i tried to convince myself that i was a
product guy in early days the hubspot so
i read everything i could about it
design books i've read everything about
steve jobs and
you name it and i just tried to get
really smart on it and i was the truth
is i just was not good at it and we
hired one product manager didn't work we
finally found a product manager that uh
i liked and we sort of built around
um
and i was like oh i see i don't actually
have that dna i'm not good at this and
it took me a while to
it took me seeing someone who's actually
really good at it to understand that i'm
actually shitty at it
and i was like oh i get it and then then
i had to figure out well how do i manage
this type of person
and the way i managed this person and
the team was by really giving them a lot
of free reign like giving them
very wide boundaries and just saying hey
you guys figure out and gals
what's inside this box this is what the
box looks like and what was that box
like we need to attract this type of
customer we need to grow by this we need
to like we need to we can't have these
people churning out
i'll show you show you the box
it's a box i've drawn on white boards in
the product organization a million times
like
here's the crm platform
okay mark bryan's literally drawing a
box right now by the way he's got like a
professor-style channel oh you guys all
right so i'm right so on the board i'll
describe what i'm drawing i drink this
is good we have a youtube channel box on
the bottom that's like the hubspot crm
keep drawing by the way we have a
youtube channel this is going to be on
there okay it's a crm platform on the
bottom and then on top are apps like we
got a marketing app we have a sales app
we have a service app we have a content
management system we have an ops app now
and basically i would draw that on every
board
and what's it what's interesting about
the dimensions of it is the vast
majority of the space in the drawing is
in the big box at the bottom which is a
message to the developers the product
people like hey the power inside of
hubspot isn't a whole bunch of
applications that we're going to
buy and glue together and cobble
together we're gonna build a killer
platform and that platform's gonna have
workflows as part of it it's gonna have
social media as part of it and messaging
it's gonna have a set of shared services
and then the apps themselves are
actually quite a bit smaller but they're
all just woven together pieces of the
underlying platform and they got it and
uh and actually they they extended it in
big ways and then i said i want a
marketing business it's going to be a
billion dollar business growing x
percent and this year i want a sales box
and in that sales box i want that to be
a
whatever 300 million dollar business
growing y percent and i just draw out
the numbers and draw the boxes
and they would decide what to put in
there based on what they thought and
what customers were saying and where
they thought the world was going so i
managed them very very very loosely i
managed other parts of hubspot very very
tightly but the product worked very very
loosely but i heard i've heard that you
you are like that most of the time and
then when something isn't going well you
get down and dirty in your heart and
you're like we have to we have to nail
this
i do i will i'm either at a very high
level or go very very deep
and um
one of the first things that you said to
me was like
um keeps you know you didn't you didn't
mean it this way but you're like keep
being you keep being crazy yes and if
anyone says anything to you about what
you can and cannot say
you'd let me know yeah stay weird yeah
that's what it was it was staying weird
you're like
awesome to stay weird down so i just
naturally thought it would stay weird
because what makes you you is you're
you're [__] dude you're weird
yeah
well dude so
chuck bryan has a book so if you google
brian halligan guitar he bought jerry
garcia's guitar and you could like see
the price on there um which i was like
that's weird that like i know that you
bought a two million dollar jerry garcia
guitar that's crazy
and also he has this book called like
what the grateful dead can teach you
about social media
about marketing about marketing um so
a lot a lot what can i learn from the
grateful dead give me that four points
we're gonna have to do a whole other
podcast about it it's just too much
i uh do you know so there's this company
called i bet you definitely know what it
is nuggs.net you know yes
okay so nugs is this okay so the reason
i know about it was the hustle started
in
this small apartment that i rented
for really cheap but it was craigslist's
old office so craigslist was
doing like 900 million dollars a year
and craig newark basically owned the
whole thing and he was based out of this
little shitty apartment that i ended up
renting right when he moved out
and we shared it with nugs.net
is this company that it started out
basically i think only for grateful dead
but basically
i remember as a kid sean i don't know
you probably even have an older brother
so you probably didn't do this but like
you would
meet people on the internet and you
would get their address and you would
mail them a tape and they would mail you
a tape back and you would have a live
recording of a particular concert and
nuggs.net was the the platform or the
message board kind of where you could
like meet other people who went to a
pearl jam or a grateful dead concert and
you trade tapes i don't even know what
they do now
now it's cool now it's a live broadcast
for concerts it's awesome
so you want to see a giant you want to
see a dave matthews concert tonight
you know they're probably broadcasting
it uh it's awesome now they've really
come a long way that's an awesome app
now and they like so they started as
this like it was like the exchange i
guess now they have like a thing and we
were talking about the grateful dead and
we can learn them these people have the
most like it's you know there's like a
few things like moms are like really
culty about like products for their
babies um dog lovers are kind of like
this um health nuts it can be like this
and like grateful dead fans yeah like
the people who are into like fish
grateful dead this type of stuff it's
it's their engagement is off the charts
so i'll give you a non-secretary giving
in a weird way the grateful dead
inspired hubspot and here's what here's
how
so sam
let's say you're going to a rolling
stones concert
and
you show up with like your big camera
and your giant like recording equipment
what happens when you get to the door
they say bounce you know you can't
and what are they what is the grateful
dead say
i think they have a section where you
can sit special taper section for you
like come on in
sit right here put your microphone up
like get your gear all set up come early
you got like vip access and you go and
tape and and then you listen to the
concert and one of the things about the
grateful dead that's interesting like
when you see the rolling stones you see
them in boston they play a certain set
list and they play it very precisely and
they're very good then they go to new
york
and what do they play
it's it's totally different exactly
yeah most bands do the same thing but
grateful dead it changes every night
every time and sometimes by the way
sometimes it's terrible but usually it's
quite good and so you tape in boston and
then you go to new york and they do you
know giant stadium for two nights then
you go to philly and you follow them
around and by the end of the show you've
got like you know 15
shows on you know of your tapes and you
pick the two or three real good ones and
you make copies for your friends and you
send them around to your friends and
then you're at some fraternity party or
whatever and somebody's playing the
state and the person next to you is like
hey what's this crazy gypsy music
they're playing you'd be like oh this is
a grateful dead why don't you come with
us we're going on to on the spring on
the summer tour this summer come along
with us the grateful dead
were the first and best inbound
marketers they gave away all their
content and they used the best content
to spread the word around the internet
they were they were very inspirational
behind inbound and content marketing and
all that stuff they were the first ones
they were the really first ones to
really embrace
uh viral marketing in in a super super
modern way and back then there was an
email marketing and there wasn't like uh
social media but they were
big on message boards and the message
boards were on fuego
i think the the live music space is
interesting to me and there's a few
opportunities that i've seen so there's
this company that is
streams live concerts on apple tv uh i
forget what it's called um but they
by the way that's exactly what nuggs
does yeah and this company they just
built like a uh they don't stream live
ones but it's like it's like a it's like
netflix for concerts and they were doing
like that's a cool idea it was pretty
cool they were doing about 20 million
dollars a year in subscription revenue
and i think they bootstrapped it they're
based out of england look i'll look up
the name in a second and then the second
thing that i always thought was
interesting and it totally bombed with
song kick sean did you know song kick
yeah no
okay so song kick what it did was they
basically you would say where you're
living and it would tell you all the all
the concerts happening that day or for
any other day email
yeah so they have this huge email it's
basically like an email marketing
business and they raise a little bit of
money and it complete i think it went i
think they it failed and was sold for
nothing but the thing about the live
music space is like a lot of people have
tried to build stuff in there because
it's fun right it's like you're
passionate about it but very few
companies have been able to pull it off
and make money um another one was uh
like um
something fm what was that called uh i
forget what it was called it was started
in san francisco fm turntable fm and
it that bomb too it didn't work out
nothing there's rights problems there's
rights problems that's one problem for
music and the other thing is the trick
in business is i think to do what you're
passionate about that not every other
human is also passionate about
right because you want to follow your
passion but you don't want to follow
everyone's passion because that's just
competition
right like brian nerds out about inbound
marketing he's passionate about
something that 99 of other people don't
even know or care about so that's the
beauty of hubspot and how you can build
a giant company like website because
you're going to go further than
everybody else live music okay yeah
great here you go you and every other
really good point 20 year old wants to
do it
i'm not a huge beer teal fan but he said
he said something interesting in his
book
he said in order to be successful you
need to be right about something that
everyone else thinks you're wrong about
and they think you're wrong about it for
a long period of time yeah i i think
that's rightish yeah somebody says
something like that they go investing is
pi is
being a great investor is investing
things that everybody agrees with you
about later
yes
it's called quello by the way q-e-l-l-o
and they claim that they have two or
three million subscribers
uh very interesting business
we got a wrap uh we got another pod
right after this actually brian this is
great thanks for coming on uh thanks for
having me this is fun you're a fun hang
i like this i didn't know yeah
before this so this is cool i want to
have you on again the things next i want
to talk about is like the evolution how
you go from like just
being scrappy to now you're like very
corporate ceo that's a that's a it
sounds like an insult that's not an
insult i mean like you're able to like
manage thousands of people and like very
few people have been able to pull that
off so i wanna i wanna tell we can talk
about the ceo journey and how it changes
over time it's interesting but we
definitely have some more grateful dead
down
i'm down well thank you man this is
awesome this is it's kind of your
podcast now so anytime you will come on
let's do it okay
[Music]
travel never looking back